Ah yes Shepherd’s three or four New Year’s rake A day
allowed What’s the work What’s the work He really spent time Guidance Dan Mundi Subtitles Tinting Color
Basic finish Moral
hate ul ce Water must never be done Don’t go now
Any other guy for the training establishment
You’re abyss  Immigration now
add the front end wmf wmf good luck wea blue moon what can be difficult we don't
have a
car we
're going to pour anything we're going to find out 5 ios6 cancer or cancer
try altruism
4 If
you want to get hydrotherapy, how easily do I get you like this? Like before
I know the human body, but
members sunscreen quality bee pain
[clap]
ah
compaq sensibility um
ear shawl
ecounsu healing 5 every night 2
pairs love cypung easy oo ah ah
[clap]
over to whether
uh [clap] ah ha ah ah
cut off  So you, ah
, writing a scenario is actually such a lonely and lonely task. In fact, I'm
not writing a scenario on behalf of a country, but
Erica must have 4005 Pas s on Skype.
Applause]
Thank you to my wife, who always inspires me a lot someday, and also to our cool Parasite actors who brought my lines to the screen wonderfully.
I will when I first add
Pack 1 character What ah why so much in my heart 4 uh Just like
there is Hollywood in the United States,
when you think you will become Korean Chungmuro ​​1 after death Ki 5s As a medical friend of an anchor,
all film makers and storytellers are in my heart.  I would like to share the honor
Thank you more  rt shard row at the beginning of the 2nd month 3